I'm sure you heard of this guy top G
what have you seen him already anything
good what your videos yeah we watched
him a good amount I just want to go
through some of his most popular Clips
with you and get your thoughts four
girls flew in I sat them all down at
table they're all like who's this chick
who's this chick told them all the truth
well just straight sat there just sat
there and said listen
I've been with you all I'm starting a
webcam business I'm Gonna Get Rich some
of you either gonna come with me to the
top of the mountain or if you're pissed
off you can fly home so a woman can't go
around [__] people and pretend it's
the same as a man running around from
people well do you think that a man
sleeping around is the same as a woman
sleeping around yeah I I don't see the
the I don't agree with him on this point
100 the way he thinks it no no it's hard
to separate it from society because you
can't just run around sleeping with
multiple women no no woman tolerates
that like no good woman's gonna want you
if you're just running through chicks is
that what you're saying yeah and do you
really want to be running through chicks
while you're no no I'm not I don't know
someone else I don't I don't vouch for
this stuff like I don't go around
sleeping with a bunch of chicks it's
also just such a big time waster we were
talking about that earlier like you got
to go on the date you gotta talk to them
like they're not they're not
entertaining
they don't make you laugh you make them
laugh and it's like it's just work you
know what I'm saying it is a lot of work
it is too much work absolutely not the
same if I a man can only cheat if he
loves someone else if I have a woman who
I truly love and I go out and [__] and I
come back to her and I don't care about
her and I only love my girl that's not
cheating see that's why I disagree with
him if you love someone you go out and
screw somebody else that's cheating yeah
I guess it's cheating but like at the
same time you could also fully love a
woman go out sleep with someone else
have no emotional investment to them and
still be just as equally in love but a
woman couldn't do that if they go and
sleep with someone else you don't think
so that's true you think women can I
think some guys can do it some people
can do it some women can do it some men
can do it you can't make a brunch you
don't think it's gendered there's no
broad statement you can make about that
if you're a woman and you're going to
any kind of defense glass stop because
all that's doing is giving you some
false confidence [__] and next time
you're in a situation when you need to
run you're gonna start thinking I know
what to do you're not [__] Steven
Seagal you're a hoe you don't know [__]
the only thing women can do is Scream
and run that's not true either what you
don't think that's true no you're a
joint manipulation techniques a woman
can knee again that's true she could
move some Akita or whatever Kimbo
whatever it's called
joint manipulation do you think like
basic stuff like basic stuff yeah she
should then run when she can but you
need to like get out of a situation I
think he makes these broad statements
it's hard to agree with these broad
statements they sound almost idiotic
it's almost I mean they sound idiotic
but he's making a broader point so if
you listen to his stuff like we've
listened to his yeah it's also smaller
Clips yeah you have to listen to it
entirely so like points are probably
correct but when he speaks in these
little microcosms they make no sense I
could agree with you there so like a
quick jab a quick elbow or a quick not
even a jab like a more strategic move
than that and run but rather than
learning like you learn like you know
you see the girls go to boxing they do
their uppercuts like this and then now
they think that if they're in a fight
where there's a bunch of dudes now they
can start throwing Hollywood does that
too Hollywood makes it seem like every
woman can kick every guy's ass yeah
Hollywood's a big part of it yeah it's
[__] there's one chick Captain
Marvel
waving off Superman and all these other
people it's like just give her shut up
hoe
give her one of these
I'm joking I'm just busting your balls
all right let's go this one how can you
be high value
if 50 men or something
just been single for a long time no
unacceptable why is it unacceptable our
body count is probably the number one
most easiest way to judge the value of a
female I actually think
that 19 no no no no no I'm gonna say
this I think 99 of the world's problems
and no one's going to understand this
but if you can extrapolate if you can
listen to this statement and extrapolate
it out towards Society at Large
I think 99 of the world's problems would
be solved if females walked through life
with their body count on their forehead
because it would prevent because it
would prevent
all of the
disintegration of morals it would
prevent so many things about the world
and women would be like
to be with me as a man I don't want to
put another number on my forehead you
have to be a good man they wouldn't stop
[__] these idiots and stop being
idiots and all the idiots you would
disappear all the degeneracy would
disappear families would return what do
you think if you extrapolate it out he's
probably right you think he's right
there well like he said if you
extrapolate it out morality might be
better who knows
uh hard to agree with that but I I could
see where he's coming from I see the
broader the bigger picture just because
there's less degeneracy overall so then
families would come together yeah but
you and I've had this conversation
before I don't think it's necessarily
it's just it's just this yeah I don't
think it's just about women doing it if
men too we have to be our bodies are our
temples too we should be better but it
says you
I'm joking
you can build yourself from the ground
up if you could literally just like from
a video game just tick characteristic
boxes and build yourself nobody would
choose to be a liberal soy boy nobody
would choose to be a small weak guy who
has to cry when he gets upset everyone
when they get that application form from
God saying build yourself for your next
life would tick tall strong smart
mentally tough doesn't cry you mean they
wouldn't want blue hair and Rings all
over the place and what do you think of
that statement though of course he's
right on that one I agree I've noticed
that with a lot of the things people say
that they're fine with it's just cope
because if you took you went back to the
my career where you're back in the lobby
where God's creating you and you had the
choices to pick the boxes if you're
picking the other box than what you have
then it's just cope you know what I'm
saying a lot of guys do that real men
cry and if women can cry men can cry too
there's nothing wrong with it and there
absolutely is something wrong with it
and I'll explain to you why Life as a
man is far more difficult than life as a
woman and one of the key components of
manhood always has been and always will
be we have the ability to control
ourselves and not act emotionally
females are more emotionally driven more
emotionally impulsive than a good man
should be
saying that I felt like crying so I
cried this makes me a real man is as
stupid as me saying well I felt like
smashing his face in so I smashed his
face in this makes me a real man no the
Hallmark of a real man is controlling
himself controlling his emotions and
acting appropriately regardless of how
he feels and throughout human history
this is exactly how men had to live
their lives do real men cry I don't
think I've ever seen you cry I've never
cried in real life meaning I'll watch a
movie movies a song Oh a movie will make
you tear up yeah Opera but not nothing
in real life no except for my father
passed nothing else in real life makes
me cry do you think men have it harder
than women in life I don't know I've
never been a woman I would assume we do
why more sense of responsibility you
can't marry your way out of your life I
think if a woman wanted to she could get
married starting only fans there's a
couple backup plans I'm saying within
the moral compass in the right direction
I guess I could start managing only fans
that's my backup you better have some
backup I think a man should have
absolutely no interest in whether he's
actually happy or not if I wake up and
I'm unhappy I will do the exact that's
exactly what Grandpa used to say really
my dad yeah we're men we go to work we
provide for our family who cares about
your happiness he just wouldn't even
take it into account oh my dad wanted to
read the paper it's all he wanted to do
my mother busted his balls all the time
how do you think that like rubbed off on
you him always um because I don't know
in society they always push men's like
happy I think happiness is also a state
of mind I mean you know I'm Mr Silver
Linings yeah that's true so everything
but on the uh what do you say on the
other hand on the other hand have you
ever been too worried about your
happiness and I feel like you never
really talk about that stuff I don't
think in terms of happiness I think of
Peace so you know now I'm retired I can
afford my life Dwight can I afford a
peaceful existence not really happiness
it's that can I avoid stress my dad died
when I was in Romania and I had just
moved my business from London to Romania
and I was in this apartment
with six girls and we were supposed to
work and I just bought all new equipment
and I had to leave England and I bought
this new house and I spent all my money
right and then my dad died of course and
then um I'm supposed to go to his
funeral so I was gonna have to get up
and leave Romania fly all the way to
Alabama stay in America for a few weeks
and then I Knew by the time I came back
all the girls
all this kind of thing so I had to make
a big decision
and I remember when I first started
making my money and my dad was still
alive the first thing I did with my
money first thing I did was retirement
how much you get paid she told me I said
I tripled it you're not working anymore
so I retired my mom and I I had to make
the choice whether I stay there and
focus on the business or go to my dad's
funeral
and I remember my dad's lessons my dad
would have been Furious if I [__] up
the financial stability of the family
and of my mother and of my brother my
dad knew I loved him I spoke to him
every single day and from what he taught
me we were very he's a he's a chess
player he's a logical man what do you
think of that yeah but there's more to
it what about him being there for his
mother that's what my mom said yeah I
mean she's right and you're that much of
a top G you gotta figure out your
business why do you have to go for weeks
why couldn't you just go for a couple of
days yeah I mean I I don't think I would
skip a parent's funeral that's
definitely a bit extreme thing
women should clean so when you walk into
a house and you see mess why is your
lazy ass not doing the right thing to
start picking and cleaning [__] up why
does it just have to be women shouldn't
everyone be clean and if you don't hold
up hold up watch the whole thing watch
the whole thing women
should clean up
not only should women clean up women
should clean up unprompted and I'm going
to tell you why
it's very very simple we live in a world
where things need to be fair 50 50.
gender equality blah blah I pay for
things unprompted you don't have to ask
me to pay for [__] if we go for dinner
I'll get my will out pay at the end
don't even check the price of the bill
my card always works just bang out pay
whatever no problem unprompted if you're
with me your life is effectively free
everywhere you eat everywhere you go
where you sleep you ain't paying for
[__] you ain't getting in my car and I'm
asking you for [__] gas money
no I pay for everything instantly as a
man should so when you walk into a house
and you see mess why is your lazy ass
not doing the right thing to start
picking and cleaning [__] up so again
he's talking about himself how he pays
all the checks is he saying he goes into
one of his women's homes or is he saying
women at large so if he's paying all the
bills and that's the relationship he's
established I would agree with him they
should be clean but I think everyone
should be clean I mean he freak like
your mother yeah so if you don't want to
clean hire someone to do it I don't care
who cleans your house but your house
should be clean yeah yeah he's not
saying like if there's not a girl here
I'm just like not gonna pick up the
dirty tissue I dated one girl her shower
was so disgusting they were Footprints
where the boss wasn't growing anymore I
never went back to her place again no
that's disgusting I've seen her at that
point recently posted a question on
Twitter asking would you rather have sex
with a transsexual which is a legitimate
10 or a woman which is a legitimate one
and everyone's sitting there clicking
woman woman woman woman because they
think they're going to be gay if they do
anything else but they're not actually
thinking about the question I am so
smart I operate on so many levels higher
than the average man you people are not
thinking about the question
when I say a one and a 10 I mean
Megan Fox with a dick that's the [__]
or Hulk Hogan with a [__]
that's the girl
this is the question I'm asking Megan
Fox or Hulk Hogan so you're thinking
well I don't want to be gay so I just do
I click the girl the number one did it
you're gonna [__] Hulk Hogan there's a
[__] but he's got mustache and muscle
foot five
it's pretty gay to me that sounds pretty
gay I don't care if it's [__] that is
gay whereas Megan Fox okay he's got a
dick but maybe you can like
scoot it where are you scooting it over
is there a vagina tucked under there
poopy dick what would you do I said the
[__] I said the [__] that's a 10 and
my mom started smacking me she was like
voila we get to get the holy water can't
we just say keep your clothes on and
just perform other acts I guess that's a
tough one though that's a tough one for
sure if I have to choose it's like Megan
Fox a little guava ghoul never heard the
soul
over here only during June only during
June I don't believe in depression I do
believe in depressing the idea of
clinical depression as a disease I
reject absolutely and I do not believe
in I believe that certain things can
happen that will make you feel depressed
and I believe that it's an evolutionary
Instinct humans have to warn them that
there's something they're unhappy about
in their life right A lot of people are
pretending depression is why their life
is [__] when in reality their life is
[__] which is why they're depressed I'm
not sure because I agree with the latter
part of what he said that if you're
depressed is often something wrong
however I also know I don't understand
depression because it doesn't family so
I've never had depression so when you
see someone like a famous musician off
themselves I don't know how that
comports with what he just said like a
famous musician where their life is
going great and then they kill
themselves clearly there's something
going on in their brain that's not
normal well he said he used like Robert
Williams as an example and he's like
well because you went to therapy for
seven years and cried about your
problems every day I'm like damn like if
I had to go to therapy and well he would
talk about my he was an addict he had
demons as well I don't know I do
definitely agree with him on the
depression take like I don't know I just
like I also feel like if you don't
believe that you can get depression then
like it could never it could never get
you but we don't have depression but if
you don't believe if you believe you
it's not even real how could you ever
get it think about like how you were
taught from a kid the reason you feel
that way is because the way you raise
you don't think it's under the I don't
know if his assumption is correct though
I I don't think his assumption is
correct I think there's something called
clinical depression it's true and it
happens to people I feel bad for them I
have empathy because I I don't
understand it so I I I feel for someone
I couldn't imagine not being Mr Silver
Linings and always finding the bright
side in something and I think the worst
thing you can do for a son is just to
raise him in a bubble my dad used to
just randomly push me over I'd be like
free not hard
get up boy okay Mom would be like why
are you doing that he's like you get
pushed over that's life my Mom hated
that she did that to me but uh yeah I
couldn't give him nothing but praise
what do you think of that yeah his first
point was that you shouldn't raise your
son in a bubble is absolutely correct I
mean you had we were very fortunate with
you you went to public school in the
city you took public transportation you
were out there you were on this I don't
say on the street but you had a normal
life you see parents today with play
dates nothing but play dates for kids
that's lame I hate Play-Doh I have sons
who are too busy buying nfts and saying
money in on skinny little arms and go to
crypto conventions and be a dorks I will
not have nerds as children I refuse to
have a nerd carry the lame tape if my
son is a nerd one of us has to die him
or me and I'll challenge him to Mortal
Kombat so that reminds me of when your
mom was talking about what a great
athlete you were in high school and I
said no
no you refuse to do push-ups and then I
showed your mom the photo of me when I
was your age and I showed that's what
hard Works look like yeah no I wasn't I
was a a [__] with that stuff I was I I
cared more about like fortnite and
becoming a professional there than I did
about hockey the advantage was or the
thing that made it okay was that you
were skinny kid you still were muscular
and you played Sports yeah I wasn't sure
if you were playing fortnite I mean I
didn't like fortnite yeah it was at all
super gay
[Music]
headshots I did not like it your mother
fought me on that and she let you and
encourage you to do it which I guess you
could say led us to where we are now
yeah don't tell Mom I said that yeah
we'll give her credit mom was always
super supportive of whatever I was
pursuing doing push-ups except doing
push-ups for hockey I wanted you to do
yoga I wanted you to get be the best
goalie yes
yoga is gay but I'm gonna go play
fortnite for six hours I have a rag for
my hand because it smells so much you
know I actually used to do that I would
have a rag on my lap because if I was
sweating in a game so
pull up to the gas station put gas in
the Rari walk in mask mask no I ain't
got one well then I won't serve you so
the gas is free because I'll put gas in
you want money or not cause I'll leave
right now the gas is free I call police
it's like [__] call them so I take
the euros and I throw on the floor
get out go to get in the [__] Yard
Man I'm paid now yeah I paid you go to
get in the Rari some guy goes you should
have respect I said respect for what he
goes you're you should wear a mask I
said I don't wear a mask where I'm from
because when you're in Spain now I said
your government should have respect for
you instead of making you a [__]
slave [__] no you must wear a mask
what do you what do you think of that
though like I don't know if they're
gonna try to pull some uh some other
mask nonsense for the next election year
these are the employees at Ace Hardware
in [__] Seattle what a [__] punk
[__] Interactive I think we're getting
closer to a 1776 moment so I think of
something else like that happens I think
there's going to be some serious
pushback like too many people have woken
up since then yeah I think so too I
think the red pill is real the red pill
is real I love to hear that I I say that
but then I also wonder if I'm in an echo
chamber of this space because I watch a
lot of it and it's where I surround
myself no I definitely I know I am
because then also when I go out into the
real world and I interview people and I
see like the majority of people's
thoughts I'm like oh [__] a lot of you
guys are still sleeping so if the masks
do come back I think they're gonna have
to do something else remember when the
pandemic first started you and I were in
Boston and we were going to Chinatown to
get dim sum and somebody looked at us or
commented that we never Mass on outside
that happened all the time yeah that was
the beginning though and I thought I
stayed away from Boston after that no
and then we would get looks from like
the other townies for going to Chinatown
like are you serious yeah but they're
they're racist anyway they don't like
Chinatown they've got the best dim sum
walking distance we got [__] Speedy
Trends dude I want a way out of here for
I mean I'm gonna [__] live here the
rest of my life what would you do if
your son was gay
well would you rather
oh daughter or a gay son I don't know I
don't only have a son it's hard to say I
would say a hoe daughter because it's
gonna be a gay ho son that sounds bad
but but every gay guy I know is not
conservative in that aspect that is true
that is true I would not disown my child
if he was gay I don't care right I would
not allow my child to be a degenerate
person if he was gay in his own privacy
in his own private time I wouldn't care
if he was a gay rights activist and he
was walking around in bondage gear on a
gay pride plane in public then I would
disown him not because he's gay because
he's degenerate as a person I don't like
degeneracy I think degeneracy is
repulsive I think that's a great Point
yeah I mean that's that's a pretty
legitimate point but we've had this
conversation where Pride events in
particular have become degenerate events
yeah no I saw this with my own two eyes
I remember going there and I was
thinking like I I hope a lot of this is
just mainstream propaganda and it's just
people blowing stuff out of context or
maybe one thing happened and it's
reposted a million times but but even
before you were born mom and I would go
to an event called Beta Breakers in San
Francisco when I was stationed there and
there were people running this event
naked I got the impression it was the
gay community but who the hell knows men
in bondage gear assless chaps nah man
weird stuff hey whatever floats your
boat behind closed doors but not in
public all right what are your overall
thoughts on Tate I think we got a yeah
his bigger picture stuff is probably
true but he talks in a very pointed way
making very specific points about
individuals it's hard to agree with when
he says it I understand why so many
people disagree with him although I
don't understand the hate but people are
sheep so one person hates they all start
hating again one little segment of what
he says I probably don't agree with but
if you listen to the broader Point yeah
he's probably right yeah he definitely
TW a lot of that stuff intentionally
where he says something in a
controversial way but it's true so it's
technically like impossible to debate it
right you know what I mean but it was
smart and we didn't watch a lot of his
newer Clips you know now he sounds a lot
more uh philosophical he's a lot more
careful with how he says stuff but
Andrew Tate's crazy as takes is the name
of this video so we had to do the
craziest takes thank you guys for
watching make sure to like subscribe hit
the Bell join my Discord everything you
want to add that's it thanks for having
me Minion thanks Creator it was a blast
and
[Music]